[Music]
hello and welcome to every damn day
today we're gonna be reviewing our lives
with the help of the show review have
you guys seen based on an Australian
show also called Rick oh I know that
what's called for those of you who don't
know it's a show about a guy who has a
TV show where he reviews every aspect of
his life or whatever a viewer submits
for him to review so no matter what he
can't deny a review so let's see that
first clip let's see what my next review
is a Jay patty in Park City Utah Tech's
doctors tell me I have to be careful
because of all the attics in the human
cesspool that is my family but I'm not
so sure forest what's it like to be an
addict no the only thing I've ever been
addicted to is a thirst for knowledge I
guess that doesn't count them all right
don't think so all right then I'm about
to go and get myself addicted to
something stronger and more powerful
than knowledge ha those are nicely made
lines well I have never done cocaine
before and I have no idea how easy or
hard it is to get addicted to it I
confess I am quite nervous about this
but thank you bon voyage happy sailing
no oh that's like bleach in my sinuses
that's terrible have you guys done
cocaine and like how would you review it
if you have done it I have not done
cocaine you haven't done it Tana what's
your star shining one to five stars I
know you don't know cane her parents
watch the show okay she's a good pair so
we make jokes about her drinking but she
works very hard and as her left-hander
how about your friend Sarah Sarah done
cocaine and cocaine one time it was off
an iPad
I feel anxious
I don't like cocaine I don't know why I
think it's because my parents are still
married that's why no I'm really I had
my uncle was like very addicted to drugs
and you know but you wanted us to be
like yeah yeah speaking of rock and roll
boys there's a bunch of rock and roll
boys at from and that's what this clip
is about prom season was in full swing
but to gain entry to this exclusive
event I'd need an age-appropriate escort
I don't have a date myself no date to
the prom but just like when I was in
high school every teenage girl I asked
already had plans it's quite hurtful but
thank you for your honesty
excuse me I don't have a visitor's pass
so I need to make this really quick hey
I'm looking for a date to your senior
prom and I don't care who I go with hang
on now all right oh that's that guidance
counselor who's giving me grief before
I'm not supposed to be in the building
did you guys have dates your prom did
you go to prom I went to prom and
horrible and also yeah how would you
rate it the problems good I was just so
weird and like I don't
I had like a white tuxedo because all my
friends wanted to wear white tux they
were like we should all do this and I
was like well I'm afraid of conflict so
sure and I had a white tuxedo yeah I had
two dates to my prom what I changed
outfits no this is real bull I don't
believe that I had a date and then I got
a girlfriend who had been upset in the
fight but I'd already asked the girl
okay and so I went and I took pictures
with my date who was more fun and then I
went off to my with the girlfriend that
I had
time and changed and then like took
photos with her and stuff and had a
terrible night do they both know that
wasn't yeah so how would you rate it 1
out of 5 stars
I also didn't make it to the hotel party
after prom and that's because my
girlfriend of the time asked me if I
wanted to go and I was like will there
be drugs and alcohol because I was very
straightedge and she was like yeah
probably and I was like I don't want to
go then and then she said on the way
back when I drove her home she said
crying
you ruined prom you should send her
pictures of me now yeah doing cocaine
hey I'm cool now last yeah last time we
met up she was a drug dealer yeah I give
it 5 stars
huh well you may have my way with a
bomb-ass date uh-huh I also managed to
like enter a raffle at the local mall
like a prom raffle and it was a mall
that was like on its way out so no one
was really there so not only did I win
the ultimate prom prize like they called
me they're like hey you win a limo a
free like like a restaurant meal for two
and a free dress and I was like that's
incredible hung up the phone then I get
another call and it's like hey we're a
store at the mall you win a free gown
was anyone else enter this contest so I
want to freaking kind yes from the mall
that's so great yeah a rule so five
stars I was in the prom court it was
like oh you're in the court you're right
there I was in the court we didn't have
king and queen we just had I think I
just really wasn't queen but we had a
court uh-huh I was like in the court and
then a fiance was the prom queen so I am
de-facto cool that's all that works
let's just kind of round that Hannah I I
tell people I didn't go to prom I did go
to prom I did not like my date I did not
want to say yes but my mom was friends
with his mom and she said if I said no I
had to say yes so you guys said no you
had to say yes my mom my mom thought you
tricked I would spend the rest of my
life
brennick not going to prom because i was
like i don't want to go with this guy
yeah don't make me go my mom was prom
queen so she's you know I'm living in
this shadow she's like you have to go
prom is like a rite of passage for the
rest of your life what a weird way for
your mom to say that she lost her
virginity on prom night I know right
passage mother I'm gonna say 0 stars 0
stars yeah I tell people I didn't go it
sounds like your mom robbed you up that
night and speaking of robbery let's see
that next clip to truly experience life
as a thief I realized I would have to
put myself at greater and greater risk
of legal consequences my crimes could no
longer be easy or simply victimize the
old and the slow
excuse me did you just take my hat no I
mean you know what if somebody did take
your hat I would like you to have mine
come on I was surprised to find that I
was incredibly talented at separating
people from their belongings
hey is that Justin Bieber or does she
just look like him no that's him what an
angelic face he's got there was nothing
I could not have for free
[Music]
when I was a kid I stole a Lego from my
friend and I was jealous because I like
really liked the set that he had and I
was like super into Legos and I felt so
horrible that I had to banish that
little Lego man from my little Lego
village because I was like I met you I
have such bad feelings associated with
him and so eventually I then snuck it
back into my friend's house and like was
like oh it's over here yeah yeah so I
I'm stealing 1 out of 5 stars
yeah sometimes stealing makes me feel
sad which is the opposite of this clip
being happy about everything the
universe brought my way was clearly a
bizarre way to go through life hey Lucy
oh look who found some effective
sunscreen after all and it was made all
the more complicated by a surprise visit
from my ex-wife Susan oh wow oh great
okay could you put the parasol down I'll
be happy to talk the thing is forest huh
I've decided that what would be best for
me and for Erik would be best for both
of us is if we were to have a little
break from you and whatever effect that
you may be having on our lives this was
terrible news but given the parameters
of this review there was only one way to
react
hey yeah I think it's I think that's
great you do i do i do i do i do i do
okay because i you know i'm surprised i
thought you were gonna like literally
freak out and start like throwing things
and he's such a good actor so good how
funny is that
he's the premise being that she's
leaving him and taking the kids yeah she
has already left him and he but he has
to be happy at no matter what so he's
reviewing happiness at all cost so how
would you guys rate your happiness on a
scale of one to five let's start with
Ryan how are you happy man
oh I'm five out of five you're five at
your house yeah I mean I've been
practicing gratitude and it's like four
I feel great Natasha seems surprised by
your response that means you murdered
someone you're so mad when an intern
took a spot that you don't even sit at
very often and he has to work there now
what you were like oh there's an intern
sitting in the spot where I like to eat
lunch oh the guy at the table yeah yeah
they put up they put up this whole
computer yeah you're as irritable as you
are too why can't I just just get some
ways to happy doesn't mean there's not
annoying things out you complain about
literally everything
it makes me he's found a way to bring
himself joy okay okay that makes sense
five out of five
what's your stars Hannah what's
your happiness how would you review it
one to five it's depressing yeah it's a
little bummer but uh
u.s. yeah I did ask any reasoning matter
look how sad everybody is with her
answer yeah that's true that's a good
point well you'll be a lie I'm a five
out of five yeah it's not a lie
sometimes you can like you know secret
happiness into your life like that
yeah the secret somebody three I'm
probably three Episode three yeah
Natasha where are you I'm a Ryan five
out of five which actually means I'm at
a three score is inflated that's what
I'm saying
so anything the curve or whatever I'm
grading on a curve
out of five his girl or fiance was prom
queen so that's what he said he's riding
that high snow yeah yeah please leave a
comment with whether or not you think
Ryan is actually happy that you what are
you happy I'm sorry Jordan at every
birthday party right here from my
Instagram where the joke is that I'm sad
because they because I'm usually happy
is it a joke I think it's a joke truth
in comedy truth in comedy oh wait I
guess we're all five out of five Ryan's
right when we're all happy maybe I was
right
[Music]